Oh what is going on you two now I have
done some weird and questionable things
in my life but this project that I'm
about to show you how this one takes the
cake
personally I wasn't sure if I was gonna
put it out like you not work so hard on
it
but if you guys remember I did a vlog on
that Alison gold girl when she did the
song called Chinese food so uh Ali
wanted to do a parody so we decided to
work on it together and the thing that
came out the other end what was I'm too
dirty
I'm just letting y'all know viewer
discretion advised and this is ba da
[ __ ]
a washcloth under my shock on a lift
an old dude in the alley really creepy
dressed like a panty I'm Japanese and
that's favourite he's looking at me like
I'm Miley Miley Cyrus he got a perm me
I'm so excited he clicks my finger
whoa excited but this is old dude that
sided and he looks really really really
lazy
oh I'm not sure what
had a poodle
the brain
go and hide your gear and possibly your
wife no one named not even existed
after 28 year-old no I mean literally 28
year old how are these parents
freely unaware of the pedo pedo
young white man
vehicle and it's footwear see what I did
not so innocent
he's the sheep I was in all the little
jailbait
oh I know
wearing ray-ban he's always at night a
middle school
you're
laughter
near in legions
I'm a panda cuz you like it if you hit
puberty I don't like it if you're ten
years old you might be wait you go catch
me on your playground watch me job that
role I'll give you pop rocks if you
touch my sock just jump in
show you my Utah because Chinese girls
take away my stress maybe later you can
come touch my Panda Express
yeah
I
leather
Hey